hey guys hi alright so we've been
promised this big triple wedding for DJ
Stephanie and Kimmy so I want to know
how chaotic this big day will be it's
just like 18 hours to film it so it's
yeah the actual shooting of it wasn't
was insane and was crazy yeah but the
actual wedding itself is for fuller
house is actually quite normal
nothing there's no it's get too crazy
yeah it's actually really beautiful but
all of all of the episodes and the
things that lead up to the wedding oh
yes great amazing I cannot wait you guys
seem like you're really close outside of
this show so I'm gonna know how are you
guys keeping in touch during this time
we're on Marco Polo a whole lot we have
our text change with the three of us the
whole cast
we're leaving lots of videos right we've
done socially distance like hellos they
came over to pick up Golden Girls face
masks that I had gotten them yeah yeah
so you know we've we've seen each other
a little bit but yeah Marco Polo and
video chat is the saving grace nice now
Andrea you know we know that John Stamos
took homie iconic blue couch from the
set so I wanna know what you guys took
home well I happen to have my mug here i
we all took home our mugs yeah I took
home Kimmy's accessories I have the
bacon and egg scarf the cupcake scarf I
have some of her iconic outfits and then
I took a cookie jar from the kitchen
that's shaped like a San Francisco house
but that's it no big ticket items like
the couch yeah were you guys surprised
that he took that couch yeah like
everybody else okay so your shocked
reactions that was true yeah okay so
Jodi what did you take I took I also
have my mug with the S on it
and then I took the the CPAP II head you
know the whole figure that was by the
stairs like the weird little dude that's
by that yeah I took his head so that's
sitting on my shelf and then I also took
a framed thing that was hanging in the
kitchen it was like this embroidered
hand stitch thing that said love is all
we need that was hanging up in the
kitchen for the whole fighting season so
very and how about you can't wait Andrea
you took Ben Franklin did you not take
Ben Franklin oh yeah the bus the
nobody's ever actually seen that I think
from right the audience perspective but
yes I took a bust of Ben Franklin which
is an inside joke that you cannot be
revealed I have a came up also and
that's much of a rule follower ticket
items we were told not to okay yeah
meanwhile I got caught been told to put
things back I feel like that would be me
- I probably grab as much as that Oh
what was that last day of shooting like
for you guys I mean I can only imagine
how emotional must have been it was very
very emotional yeah all of us all of us
had our moments and even the few weeks
before leading up to the final episode
those hit me even harder just because
the anticipation of knowing it was gonna
end but we had some pretty incredible
moments off-camera as well with our
whole crew and they were really special
and we have lots of pictures and video
recordings of those last few weeks so
those memories will never go away
yeah I'm not even like part of your crew
now I feel emotional so with that said
how much do fans like myself need to be
ready for the series finale like how
much my gonna crap I mean I I think we
haven't seen the episodes yet so I mean
I but from what we remember shooting I
think people are gonna I think we did a
really great job at sending the Tanners
off in a way that does justice to how
much people have loved this family for
the last 30 years
andrew does it still surprise you at how
much there's such a loyal fan base when
it comes to full house doesn't surprise
me at all our fans have been diehard
loyals for 30 years and we knew it five
years ago when we were pitching fuller
house to executives who are like reboot
why would anybody want to watch that
yeah we knew but we knew our fans would
show up because they have been loyal and
they have been engaged with these
characters for 30 years so I'm not
surprised at all I think that it'll keep
going the Phantom is going to stay
strong for another 30 years until we can
come back and do a third iteration of
this show well let me tell you I will be
waiting for that and I just have to say
like full house is such a big part of my
life where I not so this is like such a
big deal for me to actually get to talk
to you guys so thanks so much thank you